quem já sofreu preconceito
vocês sabiam que o preconceito ele pode
ser utilizado como uma ferramenta para a
formação de cérebros pensantes
eu sou filha de um curto mineiro e de
uma empregada doméstica na cidade de
franca no curto muito meu pai trabalhava
o patrão dele deu a casa a casa e ficava
lá dentro do terreno da área do curtume
ele morar com a família foi lá nessa
casa que eu nasci e nessa casinha vendo
químico trabalhar
eu me apaixonei pela química já desde
criancinha porque eu vi ele trabalhar
com jaleco branco aí eu sempre disse eu
quero fazer química trabalhar no curtume
e usar jaleco branco e primeiro uniforme
mais bonito que eu queria na minha filha
então eu minha mãe e ela como eu disse a
empregada doméstica quando eu tinha mais
ou menos três anos e meio ela mudou de
trabalho foi trabalhar numa casa bem
grande e como ela me levava o trabalho
com ela vou ficar quietinha ela ensino
ali o jornal que chegava na casa que era
o jornal estado de são paulo estadão
minha mãe estudou só até a 4ª série é o
antigo primário já é o fundamental
meu pai até a 5ª série aí ela ensinava
as palavras e eu peguei uma caixa de
lápis de cor e ficava colorindo as
palavras mais ou menos parecida e até
que um dia a patroa da minha mãe que era
diretor de uma escola ela foi até lá no
fundo quarto onde estava e falou olha
que bonitinho e está colorindo o jornal
eu disse não estou lendo
ela pegou a espantada perguntou minha
idade e pediu por um piauí welington e
aqui pra mim hoje perfeitamente o texto
pra ela ea partir daí eu tive a minha
primeira oportunidade na vida que já era
início de ano já tinha completado quatro
anos ela falou da minha mãe eu posso
levá la para a escola durante uma semana
ela acompanhar a vaga dela e assim
aconteceu eu comecei a primeira série do
ensino fundamental com quatro anos de
idade
fui estudando pessoal então até chegar o
ensino médio passamos ali muitas
humilhações
além das outras humilhações que nós
filhos na escola meu pai falou eu não
vou mudar você escola você vai estudar
vai continuar nessa escola vai estudar
vai mostrar que você é a que vai ser
alguém na vida estuda para tirar melhor
nota da sala e sempre assim terminam o
ensino médio entrei na usp e na unicamp
e da unesp com 14 anos de idade
ficamos felizes da vida
aí caiu a ficha tá escolhi ali conversei
com os professores escolheu nikão que
mas como morar em campinas
vamos lá fazer a matrícula então
encontramos um pensionato só que não
estava incluído numa alimentação café da
manhã é nada disso
mas a universidade era período integral
é igual o sábado todos os dias ali na
unicamp e o pãozinho que vinha aquele
golzinho pequeno que vem no bandejão
todos os dias e se levá lo pra que o
pensionato a noite era minha janta e
sempre assim às vezes de uma fruta
banana laranja também levava isso vai
servir o jantar mas logo na primeira
semana já preocupada como nem e comendo
final de semana na minha um pensionato
estava incluído em uma alimentação não
tive vergonha não pessoal
conversei caxias do bandejão expliquei a
situação e pedir pra elas que se toda
sexta feira ela discute um belo banho
seu começo no final de semana
toda sexta feira que eu passava lá pegou
um pano de chão elas me arrumava de uma
sacolinha com 78 até 10 pãezinhos
essa era minha corrida do final de
semana eu não via a hora de chegar à
segunda feira para poder usar no
bandeijão mesmo assim foi pessoal
já no segundo semestre já conseguiu uma
bolsa de iniciação científica aí já
começou a melhorar
aí eu vou conseguir dar 50 100 reais pra
minha mãe gente ela ficava um dos filhos
terminei a graduação com 17 anos de
idade filhas conheceu mestrado que o
mestrado foi um projeto da petrobras
lá na cidade paulina quer do lado de
campinas e estava com um problema no
querosene de aviação levar esse problema
da unicamp resolver
saíram três teses rumo foi a minha
terminou o mestrado eu queria trabalhar
na síntese de produtos farmacêuticos o
texto orientador e orientadora até me
disse joão eu tenho parceria com o
professor na universidade de clemson na
carolina do sul e de acordo com o
andamento do seu trabalho você pode
ficar lá um ano fazendo parte da sua
pesquisa assim foi
aí chegou o anel os resultados
caminhando bem a eles então foram joanna
vamos sentar e conversar eu acho que tem
pode pra lá pra universidade de criança
na carolina do sul
eu tenho que te falar que ela é é um
estado super racista então estamos
apenas alertando pode chegar
principalmente porque senão eles iam me
avisaram que ela sim pessoal fui foi o
pior ano da minha vida foi um ano que eu
vivi como fantasma invisível porque eu
morei no alojamento da universidade lá
as pessoas
o racismo é tão forte passa de pai para
filho é uma coisa assim enraizada nas
casas na cabeça das pessoas
eu chegava a pedir um xerox ninguém
olhava pra mim é chegar a um branco
pediu um charuto eles faziam a a minha
sorte é que tinha no grupo do meu
orientador cinco europeus eram meus
amigos então eu só tinha amizade com a
linha orientadora esses cinco europeus
pessoal eu sofri demais esse ano mas eu
entendo que eu estava adquirindo muito
conhecimento e sofrer bastante mas no
final de uma recompensa por que
publicamos aquele trabalho daquele um
ano nas melhores revistas americanas e
tive o convite para fazer o
pós-doutorado em harvard
se eu tivesse desistido o convite nunca
teria aparecido
aí voltei pra unicamp terminou o
doutorado e fui fazer o pós-doutorado em
harvard
a pesquisa estava sem proposta para em
torno de dois anos
só que infelizmente quando estava mais
ou menos um ano e meio de pós-doutorado
no mês faleceu a minha irmã meu pai a eo
vinho levou tempo a terminal pós
doutorado nesse meio tempo minha mãe
ficou muito doente
aí eu tomei a decisão de voltar pro
brasil e cuidar também amanhã lá aquela
tristeza e logo surgiu o convite na
escola técnica para trabalhar mais uma
coisa importante que eu quero mostrar
também pra vocês que nessa trajetória
eu sempre dei não ao vitimismo eu usei
tudo o que eu sofri humilhação
preconceito aqueles xingamento a fé como
ferramenta para vencer na visita logo
surgiu estava em franca tem 1 50 dias o
concurso nessa escola técnica fez o
concurso passei comecemos gente eu estou
bem raro tipo a trabalhar numa escola
técnica e ali naqueles ano e chegará
aqueles alunos a escola se um problema
de baixa escolar dos alunos até
animado que eu tava rua gente aí eu
peguei e liguei um dia fui orientado
pela de harvard
eu lembrei rocha qual é uma pessoa pode
levar na vida e falou assim joana
levantar a bunda da cadeira é porque
você estudou e round você tem que
trabalhar no melhor laboratório de
pesquisa melhores universidades e pode
fazer a diferença naquele lugar menor
que você encontrar na sua vida
aí eu comecei a acordar gente aí o que
eu fiz está eu comecei ali a pensar que
podia tá fazendo aqui diferente porque
nessa escola aquilo ela fica numa
fazenda periferia da cidade
a maioria dos alunos é unido social
muito baixo e muitos alunos ali vivendo
na vulnerabilidade utis com problemas de
droga prostituição e tanta gente como
conta mudando isso aí tive uma idéia
falecido olha a iniciação científica que
é tradicional na na na graduação
trazendo os para a educação básica de
ensino técnico
aí comecei a fazer isso já submetido um
projeto aqui para a psp que a fundação
de amparo à pesquisa do estado de são
paulo já conseguiu as bolsas de
iniciação científica aí comecei a
desenvolver projectos únicos alunos e o
importante aí eu comecei também o
pessoal achou mapa trabalhar não aquele
aluno que tem a melhor nota melhor
presença não conhece trabalhar com
aqueles piores não tem problemas com
drogas e prostituição
aí foi reunir pedir por chamas salles
marcou reunião e comecei a trabalhar com
esses alunos com isso que ninguém quer
que eu falei nós temos que tentar mudar
a vida dessas pessoas porque senão o
final temos o que é uma cadeia a menina
grávida lhe bem cedo
aí eu comecei ali há o problema da
escola quer invasão ensino aprendizagem
os problemas da cidade de franca que são
os resíduos gerados no setor
coureiro-calçadista porque 16 gols né
tem conhecimento franco conhecida como a
capital do calçado esse ano de 2018
programação de franca produzir 27
bilhões de pares de calçados
então uma coisa muito grande só tem
compensação pessoal
a quantidade de resíduos gerada é muito
grande ali né comecei a desenvolver a
pesquisa aliado aos problemas repetindo
isso que são os
vídeos gerados aqui na cidade esta idéia
naquela cadeia produtiva se você tem aí
um sapato de couro uma bolsa de couro e
tapete de corpo bonito é o estofamento
do carro então nessa cadeia produtiva
aquele corpo que chega do frigorífico no
curto ele é beneficiado vai trabalhar
ali
depois no final vai transformar isso que
eu falei calçado couro então nessa
transformação franca gera por de 218 mil
quilos de resíduos 218 toneladas de
resíduos por dia e frank em torno de 370
mil habitantes consome uma quantidade
diária de água equivalente ao dobro da
população tá então ou seja vamos aliás
se começar resolver projeto com esses
alunos resolver esses problemas está
resolvido desenvolvemos ou seja vários
projetos de pesquisa da e centos de
algum deles aqui
um deles nós conseguimos extrair o
colágeno é aquele produto maravilhoso
utilizado né em anti rugas utilizado nas
indústrias alimentícias cosméticas e
farmacêuticas porque esse colágeno
tradicionalmente no mercado ele custa em
torno de 130 reais o quilo
nós conseguimos extrair colágeno um
resíduo de couro empresário tem que
pagar para depositar no appel a um valor
de 80 centavos o quilo
produzimos pessoal
um calçado antimicrobiano teve um dia
com o aluno chegou ao flu joana
minha mãe tem diabetes e ela tem
problemas de rachaduras que tem dia que
sangra o pé dela aí desenvolvemos um
sapato ou seja compramos antimicrobianos
e tudo isso acompanhado por um
dermatologista e tapsola musses
antimicrobianos no ensino como se fosse
um copo
coloque se produz um copinho ele tem uma
tampa aí quando está fazendo coro
colocamos esse produto e junto a ele na
água ele entra dentro do couro e faz o
sapato ou seja conforme você anda ali o
seu pé essa enzima que esse
antimicrobiano sai do couro e vai
fazendo todo o tratamento no seu pé
dependendo da lesão a esse tratamento
ele em torno de 25 a 45 dias
só desenvolvemos também um cimento ósseo
para remodelação reconstituição e
transplante de ossos por exemplo a
pessoa tem um acidente de moto perdeu
parte do osso da perna a tendência é
ficar com uma perna menor que a outra e
cimento ósseo e vai corrigir fazer toda
aquela remodelação e um importante e
depois ele favorece o crescimento do
osso novo e com o famoso novo mandato ao
da pessoa cresce absorve e cimento
tudo isso já está sendo testado em
hospitais pessoal repetindo mais uma vez
tudo isso com a participação de alunos
na faixa de 14 a 18 anos de idade um
trabalho super importante pele humana
artificial para ter os pães e testes
tecnológicos o que nos levou a
desenvolver isso um dia estávamos um
porto não assistimos um acidente um
funcionário estava carregando um galão
com ácido sulfúrico 20 litros de ácido
sulfúrico sem tampa foi subir uma escada
esse currículo
o astro teen sobre ficou cego na hora
que em 95% do corpo de uma missão que os
alunos vão estudar procurar qual pele
animal se aproxima mais da pele humano e
verificamos que a pele suína tem 78% de
compatibilidade com a pele humana
conseguimos fazer transformar as 75 por
e 78% em
por cento de compatibilidade e essa pele
ela essa no caso de transplante
utilização em queimados ela fica para
sempre o paciente que ela serve de
estrutura de apoio com a pele do
paciente crescer sobre ela e por
questões de estética taques vê é uma cor
branca
nós já estamos produzindo essa pele
humana artificial próximas às cores
negra e vermelha e amarela
o pessoal investir em educação
científica
tá é a peça chave na construção de uma
sociedade democrática mais humana e
sustentável que somente por meio da
educação nós conseguiremos uma
transformação social efetiva e dando
chance ao jovem
aquele que ninguém quer que todo mundo
excluir porque a gente eles têm
sentimentos em falar de mim mas para o
juiz nem falar pra ele fala
joana ninguém olha pra gente o pessoal
as pessoas nos vêem como lixo e dá
oportunidade a essas pessoas e um fato
também marcou é quando um dos alunos
recebeu a primeira bolsa de iniciação
científica a mãe foi lá na escola foi
nos agradecer
naquele dia o menino chegada do meu lado
mas se fosse um ano desceu hoje mello
encontrou um quilo de sal se tipo gente
fazendo almoço ea felicidade das pessoas
e nós temos
tá até o momento 15 patentes
internacionais em 30 países 80 prêmios
nacionais e internacionais
isso aqui é papel porque nada diante do
que eu estou falando para vocês dos três
maiores prêmios que disciplina a minha
vida em 2016
um pai chegou até mim agradecer a filha
tinha 15 anos e era garota de programa
desde os 13 anos uma cidade próxima a
franca ele disse joana ela começou a
fazer iniciação científica com você
alimonti que vai ser pesquisadora largou
a vida de garota de programa
o ano passado 2017 uma mãe vem me
agradecer
joana meu filho de 16 anos ele saia da
escola vai ficar no meio do tráfico
ele diz que vai ser pesquisador ele quis
largar essa vida e até mudei de bairro e
isso foi inteligente da parte dela você
mudar de bairro ele não encontrar mais
aquelas pessoas
esses dois alunos eles entrarem química
no final do ano na universidade federal
do triângulo mineiro em uberaba serão
nossos serão futuros químicos e um dado
interessante todos os alunos que fizerem
iniciação científica comigo
a maioria está fazendo química hoje
universidade
e o terceiro prémio que foi muito
importante o ano passado deu uma
palestra na fundação casa em franca
é aqui que tem chateado porque eu vi
minhas crianças de 12 500 e lidiane que
tinham cometido o delito
no mês passado a psicóloga me ligou e
falou assim joana tem três garotos daqui
estão prestes aqui a sair e eles querem
da escola estudar na escola e fazer
projeto de iniciação científica com você
desses 31 matou o outro roubou o outro
era traficante gente conseguir os
plantão a sementinha nessas pessoas
é possível a educação no brasil tem
futuro é possível a ciência no brasil
tem futuro é possível pessoal é possível
desenvolver pesquisa de ponta dentro de
uma escola pública dentro de uma escola
de educação básica de ensino técnico
basta nós professores pesquisadores
levantar a bunda da cadeira e fazer a
diferença porque nós trabalhamos num
laboratório de bancada de cimento nada
de reclamar
tá o que ele está dentro de nós e cada
um tem um querer diferente
a educação é a arma mais poderosa para
venceremos os obstáculos da pista
mostrei como o preconceito ele pode ser
utilizado como uma ferramenta para
vencer na vida para formação de cérebros
pensantes e não obtive mesmo ficar se
lamentando o brasil tem futuro basta
acreditar nos jovens
obrigada